thank you very much thank you thank you
this is a Holy Week when religious
believers of course the nation will
observe Passover Good Friday and Easter
millions of Jewish families begin
Passover at sundown tonight a sacred
unbroken tradition that traces back to
the ancient land of Egypt and on Sunday
we celebrate our beautiful wonderful
Easter which we all look forward to we
would have many Easter's together in
churches in the future we're getting
closer you see the numbers we're getting
much closer to getting our country back
to the way it was we have now an extra
two countries that have been attacked
184 they're being attacked as we speak
but we'll all win at some point we're
going to all win we're going to do it
sooner than people think earlier today I
spoke with 10,000 of America's faith
leaders to thank them for raising the
spirits of our people during these very
difficult days well we may be physically
apart we can use this time to pray to
reflect and to focus on our personal
relationship with God I also spoke with
more than 3000 mayor's county
commissioners and state and tribal
leaders to provide an update on our
administration's ongoing drive to beat
the virus to crush the virus and that's
happening it's happening I think if you
look a little bit more quickly than
people thought maybe a lot more quickly
I hope and it's something that all over
the world we're watching but people are
watching us and seeing what we're doing
and they're very impressed we're dealing
with many countries right now many many
countries and we're giving them whatever
information we were able to Deline I
just spoke with the representatives
of the UK and I think that they're great
Prime Minister is doing much better
today or at least better but certainly
he's had a tough bout and he's still
going through a tough time but he seems
to be doing better and that's good and
we we send our regards to Boris and his
family and his friends all the people
that really love him he's become a very
popular before this happened became a
very popular prime minister he's doing
an excellent job he loves their country
he loves our country so we appreciate
everything he's done and hopefully he's
gonna be okay speaking of great people
and people that have done a fantastic
job
I have Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
with us and I'd like to ask Mike to say
a few words and then I think what we'll
do in order to get him back to the State
Department we'll take some questions and
we'll then go on with the rest of what
I'm going to say then we'll take some
questions after that and then vice
president pence will take over so Mike
Pompeo please Thank You mr. president
under the president's leadership my team
and I at the State Department are doing
our part to protect the American people
from the virus and importantly to get
them home as you know when many
countries shut down their rail lines the
buses their infrastructure systems the
capacity to get out of those countries
they were trapped they were stranded the
State Department swung into action since
January 29th we have now repay treated
over 50,000 United States citizens back
to their homes for more than 90
countries more than 490 flights back to
the United States from all across the
world
this this worldwide scale of our
repatriation efforts is without parallel
in our lifetime we are coordinating with
foreign governments militaries Airport
authorities medical units transportation
companies hotels you name it we're
working with them to make sure the
American people get back to be with
their families you can see behind me the
map of the flights that we have brought
back people from all across the world
every day I get a chance to hear some of
the remarkable stories from our team let
me give you just a couple of examples
our mission in Peru
working with the Peruvian
military and police forces to send river
boats up the up the river to get
citizens that were stranded deep inside
the Amazon forest our mission in Nepal
made sure their woman who was running
low on medication could get what she
needed a pharmacy before tea before
boarding an evacuation flight that
brought her back here in Honduras after
the government imposed very strict 24/7
curfew in closed airports our embassy
sprang into action for stranded
Americans thousands of them three oh boy
told one of our consular officers just
before he boarded the flight thank you
for helping me get back home to my dad
pretty neat
we received similar messages from lots
of people they're proud to know that the
country will not leave them stranded
we're going to get them back home one
woman wrote quote I was in tears when I
received the email approving our flight
back to the United States god bless the
United States of America and the nether
said I felt like I had allies there that
actually treated me like a person or a
family member not just a number the
repatriation task force the State
Department a consular officers have done
great work I want to thank our partners
in the Department of Defense who have
helped with some of these flights back
home and other government agencies our
sisters and brothers across the United
States government in this administration
that have helped get these people back
and then lastly aside from our
repatriation efforts we continue to help
countries around the world as well
we've got cDC officials helping these
countries with expertise and all the
things that these countries need to get
their citizens safe and healthy and back
so that we can get the economy all
across the world the global economy back
on its feet when this crisis is over
thank you
we'll see if anybody has any questions
for Secretary of State
anybody please mr. secretary how do you
know when you're done because I imagine
there are Americans and all corners of
the world and
someone's gonna pop up and say I want to
go home now it's a great it's a great
question we still have several thousand
people that we're working they identify
themselves every day new people find
themselves in difficult place look we're
gonna be done when people can travel on
their own again these people traveled
abroad on vacations or with their church
and we're intending to get back on their
own we hope that day comes pretty soon
where they don't have to rely on the
State Department to get them back home
but know this in in the meantime we're
devoting all the resources we have to
get them there in often in difficult
places they're not in the capitol near
the airport or the roads are closed and
so it's not just a matter of getting a
flight down there there's a lot of work
that has to be done to coordinate to
make it all happen and get those people
available so they're sitting there when
the flight lands they can get on the
plane and then we can get them back home
and we still have several thousand we're
working on it we chip away at that
number every day but new citizens go to
the State Department website identify
themselves and say I need a little bit
help in some way and we do our best to
get that to them just as quickly as we
can we're gonna keep it up as long as we
have resources to do it
and there is a neat yes sir these
staffers have tested positive for on a
virus that they've been tested or going
into quarantine and and what does this
do to diplomatic efforts overseas if
you're pulling 50,000 people out of
state cap or national capitalist nation
capitals all of the world so the vast
majority 50,000 weren't our officers
these were ordinary citizens who were
there traveling for business or for
commercial or further trip of a lifetime
we've seen some of that in the cruise
ships but of course they're stranded all
over the world so our embassies save for
the one that is in wuhan which we did
pull everybody out of the rest of our
facilities around the world are all open
we've had a handful of our folks now
test positive but we feel like we have a
good handle on it and we're doing
everything we can to make sure that not
just the State Department officials but
our Department offense colleagues that
are working on these missions as well
we're doing so in a way that reduces
risk to them and their well-being also
do you feel like China help with helpful
information from the United States and
will there be any consequences for that
you know it's this is not the time for
retribution but it is still the time for
clarity and transparency we're still
working on this problem since there's
still data that these good people need
so that they can perform their analysis
of how to both develop therapeutics and
a vaccine and to understand where this
virus is so every country China included
every country needs to be transparent
about what's going on in their country
need to share that data we share ours
with the world so that the best
scientists in the world can get to the
right conclusions and bring this economy
this global economy back to the place
that we all want it to be as quickly as
we can every country has that
responsibility
it started in China and so they have
that special responsibility to get it
right quickly and fast ask every country
as we move forward in the days and weeks
ahead make sure we share that do it do
it right do it well when we do we'll get
this thing back up they have shared
their data sooner with the United States
yeah every country has an obligation to
share that information accurately timely
completely transparently and thoroughly
just as quickly as they can gather it
well we'll leave for another time to
evaluate how everyone did in that
[Music]
Secretariat the question the World
Health Organization has a fundraising
drive for about 700 billion dollars for
coronavirus resources China has only
donated 20 million the United States
actually has donated less so do you feel
that trying to should be giving more to
this World Health Organization effort
ends comments on the u.s. donation at
this point we're reading our funding
with respect to the World Health
Organization now this is very consistent
what President Trump said since the
beginning of his campaign organizations
have to work they have to deliver the
outcomes for which they were intended
and we need to make sure that not only
the World Health Organization but every
international organization that we take
taxpayer money and give it to them for
the benefit of America we need to make
sure it's delivering on those taxpayer
dollars the World Health Organization is
no different in that respect we have
they have to execute on the mission that
they are
designed to achieve and we've seen with
respect to the World Health Organization
here we are we have we have it hasn't
accomplished what it was intended to
deliver mr. secretary you said it all
the staffers have tested positive are
they gonna get the hydroxychloroquine
treatment is that going to be made
available to personnel overseas I don't
know the answer to that but but but know
that we'll deliver the best medical care
every place we can some of them are in
difficult places where there's not a lot
of medical help we've done our best to
move that medical assistance forward to
them in the field and whether or not you
have any updates so with respect to our
assistance to Iran we've offered from
the first day we knew that the virus had
struck the people of Iran we offered
humanitarian assistance I regret that
they they chose not to take that I've
heard I've heard people talking about
sanctions they're know the world should
know there are no sanctions that prevent
humanitarian assistance medical supplies
pharmaceuticals from going to Iran we
offer an American assistance we've tried
to help other countries get assistance
in there as well had some ability to do
that I don't have any better data than
what you've seen publicly than I could
share with you with respect to the
extent of the virus inside of Iran
so you've seen we're making sure that we
have what we need for the American
people whether that's gloves
I'll let the vice president talk to
numbers on that but at this point what
we are doing in terms of assistance is
providing what most of these countries
need to learn how to do surveillance
themselves to learn how to conduct tests
themselves to learn the things that can
reduce the peak in their countries those
the kind of things and we've been doing
this you should know the United States
has been incredibly generous we have CDC
officials like no other country in the
world out helping these nations build
out their health care global epidemic
health care infrastructure it's good
people like that you see sitting to my
right they've been working on this all
their life all around the world putting
these countries in a place where they're
better prepared for a virus like this
one
of any US diplomats or US officials
contracted the virus as they've tried to
rescue the US citizens abroad not that
I'm aware of
not that I'm aware but it's there's no
doubt I remember when we sent our team
to get our officials and about 800
American citizens non-government
citizens that were living in Rouen I
remember when we sent one of our first
repatriation flights in there we were
very careful we sent trained
professionals in but they were going
into a very very difficult very fraught
place we were blessed they all got back
with no one having contracted the virus
on that trip I'm not aware of any of our
officials that have had the virus
attacked them while they were forming
their functions trying to get people
back and so we have a number of State
Department officials who have who have
Co vat19 now and are working their way
through in fact we've had three
fatalities of local employees not us
direct hires but local people who were
working for the State Department in
embassies around the world we've had
three fatalities so far so there have
been some calls on the World Health
Organization for a leadership change
there I was wondering what your thoughts
are on that senator martha mcsalley for
example is called for doctor
I don't want it look this is not the
time to be to be doing that kind of
change there there'll be a lot of time
to look back and see how the World
Health Organization performed in the
meantime what our task is is to preserve
and protect the American taxpayers to
make sure that our resources don't go to
places that aren't going to deliver on
behalf of the American people in the
world and President Trump and I are
determined to do that has a
responsibility to get correct figures
how would you broadly characterize
cooperation with China right now there's
lots of places we've been cooperating
right they're providing us assistance
where we need it there are places on the
ground now where we do have access to
the data we need and we're deeply
appreciative that they've said they want
to cooperate we're completely prepared
to cooperate with them that cooperation
means sharing data being transparent
being upfront allowing information to
flow freely that's our expectation not
just of China though of every country
that is in this place today we
collectively we have to work our way
through this and to do that you have to
have really good data okay okay Thank
You mr. president
thank you all Thanks okay thank you just
a few days we've delivered nearly 11
million n95 masks to hotspots around the
country as you know including 6.6
million to New York and New Jersey 1.8
million to Chicago 1.7 million to
Detroit and 837 thousand to New Orleans
I spoke with the governor of Louisiana a
little while ago and they're doing
really pretty well much better than they
thought they'll be using fewer beds as
you know we built a hospital we're about
set to complete another hospital and
it's there's even a possibility that
won't they won't need it that's what we
discussed today we've shipped out more
than 8,000 ventilators and we have
10,000 almost 10,000
and an additional two thousand two
hundred new li manufactured ventilators
come online on Monday we're gonna be
sending them to various locations just
in case they need them my administration
is working with Philips to double their
production of ventilators by May and
ultimately quadruple production by later
this year high quality ventilators we're
eliminating bureaucratic barriers to
pave the way for Philips major
investments in American manufacturing
sites and sales this will help to ensure
that our country can permanently produce
enough ventilators in the future that we
can do them by ourselves we're gonna
have a big stockpile when we're finished
and we expect to be sending quite a few
to other countries to help them after
we're finished and even now we're a
couple of countries are really really in
dire need and it looks like our
projections were right on ventilators
and some states that were thinking that
would need thousands of more than they
thought will are now already taken care
of which we're very happy about
in addition beginning in May will be
receiving almost 300 million new face
masks we're gonna have masks of about
300 million they'll be starting to be
delivered in May and during the month of
June so we're ordering a big stockpile
and we're thinking about doing an extra
200 million should we need them or for
them or for the stockpile so we'll be in
a position to have something Incredibles
that'll be a total of 500 million masks
and today 750,000 new protective gowns
landed in Dallas Texas as a result of a
partnership led by the federal
government DuPont and FedEx and that's
been a great partnership that's worked
very well so we have 600 and we have
750,000 new protective gowns and these
are at a high level very high quality as
American industry steps up to help so
our America's doctors and scientists 10
drugs are now in clinical trials and my
administration is taking on Preston
actions to make new therapies and
treatments available without delay the
the doctors the lab technicians the
companies I spoke to him yesterday I
spoke again today they are coming up
with things that are I think I hope in
the very near future are gonna be very
very special very important our national
stockpile is now equipped with nearly 30
million hydroxy chloroquine pills so
we're up to about 30 million we're
distributing that by the millions you
read about state representative Karen
Whitsett who I very much appreciate her
going public but she was I think very
very much helped by this pill she saw
what I was saying on television she
thought she was in very bad shape I
don't want to go further than that but
you see her story you know her story
she's a highly respected state Rep from
Michigan and she did a she did a I think
she did a great service what she what
she's done she's in terrific shape she
looks fantastic and she was very
generous with her statements in addition
the Zathura Meissen and and zinc they
say is Inc you should add zinc now as
all has to be recommended by doctors
physicians but they say zinc I want to
throw that out there because that's
where they seem to be having the best
result so you add the zinc and the
xethru myosin and it's been we've had a
lot of good stories a lot of good
stories and we have almost 30 million
doses so we've got a lot I want to thank
Prime Minister Modi of India for
allowing us to have what we requested
from before the the problem arose and he
was he was terrific we'll remember it
later today the CDC will release further
guidance to help ensure critical
infrastructure workers can perform their
job safely after potential exposure to
the virus and so
working on that the question was asked a
little while ago about the World Health
Organization and as you know they made a
statement on June 1 January 14th I guess
it was that there was no human to human
transmission well there was they
probably made that statement in the
second or third week of December in
addition but they made it very
powerfully on January 14th and they
criticized me very strongly when I said
that we're going to shut down flights
coming in from China and especially from
certain parts of China but from China
generally we were criticized very badly
so last year and for many years hundreds
of millions of dollars has been paid to
the World Health Organization hundreds
of millions of dollars a year and last
year was 452 million dollars in China
paid 42 million before that it was 500
million in China paid less than 40
million and before that it was similar
numbers in the 400s 300s and sometimes
even in the 500s of millions of dollars
and China would do proportionally at
just a small fraction of that number and
I think they have to get their
priorities right and their priorities
are that everybody has to be treated
properly every country and it doesn't
seem that way does it it doesn't seem
that way so we're going to do study
investigation and we're going to make a
determination as to what we're doing in
the meantime we're holding back we're
going to we want to say very unfair
so the United States 452 million dollars
compared to 42 million dollars that's to
the World Health Organization that's not
good that's not good not fair not fair
at all and other countries as you know
also gave very substantially less than
the United States and the world w-h-o
World Health got it wrong I mean they
got it very wrong
in many ways they were wrong they also
minimize the threat very strongly and
not good I want to take this opportunity
to express the thanks of an extremely
grateful nation to the Americans who go
to work every day especially in these
critical industries in the midst of the
pandemic to care for and protect and
feed American people including medical
personnel law enforcement first
responders food suppliers sanitation
workers and somebody mentioned any would
you please specifically call-out
cashiers and clerks at grocery stores
who were in danger during the during the
pandemic during the epidemic they're in
danger they're really in great danger
and they've been incredible and I want
to call them out to cashiers and clerks
we grew up with cashiers and clerks and
grocery stores and they've been great
and they've really been true American
here so I want to call them out because
they're working hard and they're working
in conditions that aren't ideal but soon
they'll be ideal again as we mourn the
terrible loss of life for this and from
this this grave pandemic we're seeing
signs that our aggressive strategy to
slow the spread is working the number of
new cases is stabilizing the number of
beds necessary in so many locations I
was watching this morning New York I was
watching Louisiana you see what's going
on the numbers are changing and they're
changing rapidly and soon we'll be over
that curve we'll be over the top and
we'll be headed in the right direction I
feel strongly about that some terrible
days ahead but we're gonna have some
some wonderful days ahead and we're
gonna get this behind us this terrible
thing behind us some people will never
be able to forget if they had a loved
one if they had a great friend or a
friend but we're gonna get it behind us
this is a tribute to the discipline and
the devotion of the American people what
we've accomplished
if every American continues to strictly
adhere to social distancing guidelines
we can defeat the invisible enemy and
save countless lives that we could do it
much more quickly we're hopefully
heading toward a final stretch the light
at the end of the tunnel as I was saying
as we continue to wage all-out medical
war to defeat the virus we're also
fighting an economic war to ensure we
can quickly turn to full financial
strength we have to get our country back
we have to get going everybody wants to
get going
yesterday I asked Congress to provide an
additional 250 billion dollars to expand
to the incredibly successful paycheck
protection program you've seen what's
gone on there it's incredible actually
which is allowing our small businesses
to keep employees on the payroll and get
ready for the opening like a second
opening to protect millions of American
jobs I'm asking Congress to pass
additional funding for this program this
week as soon as possible and I think we
have pretty good understanding with the
Democrats hopefully it's going to be
bipartisan we do not have time for the
partisan games and we don't want that
the obstruction or totally unrelated
agendas we want to do this for the small
businesses and the workers and we can do
a phase four and a phase four will be
later this will be an expansion of what
we've already done because it's so
successful the 350 billion will be
expanded by hopefully 250 and if you
look at the kind of loans thousands tens
of thousands of loans to small
businesses it's a it's a great thing to
see it turn out to be more successful
and more productive than anybody would
have thought but Democrats and
Republicans are coming together to get
that job done that's a very important
job in recent days and days ahead will
restore America's health and economic
might but also dimensions of our
national strength will be brought
together I think stronger than I think
we have a chance to be stronger than
ever before we've learned a lot and we
have tremendous stimulus now
stimulus and we're going for more
hopefully we'll be doing an
infrastructure bill so we can rebuild
our roads and highways and bridges and
tunnels and all of the things that we
should be doing for our country we're
going to rebuild our country not other
countries where they don't even
appreciate it as our citizens persevere
through this present challenge we're
renewing American unity and we're
replenishing American will and we are
witnessing new American valor each and
every day we see it every day the daring
and determination of our people in this
crisis reminds us that no matter how
hard it gets no matter what obstacles we
must overcome Americans will keep on
fighting to victory and we will secure
the glorious future that our citizens so
richly deserve especially after going
through this nightmare
this evil beast so we're getting very
close and hopefully it will hopefully
it's on the other side and it will end
soon and I think it will and I just
think that the people of this country
are fantastic so we'll take a few
questions and then vice president will
take over please go ahead please thank
you sir president ABC is reporting that
your intelligence intelligence community
was warning about the virus as early as
November and produced a detailed report
about the outbreak in China wouldn't you
first learn about the intelligence and
could you have acted on it then well I
learned when I started when I learned
about the gravity of it was sometime
just prior to closing the country to
China and when we closed up the flights
coming in from China and various other
elements and then as you know we closed
up to Europe so I don't know exactly but
I'd like to see the information yeah
please a lot of Americans want to see
businesses reopened so to write more
than anybody so what specifically has to
happen
you to feel that it's safe to reopen the
country and what is your plan to do that
well I think we can say that we have to
be on that down side of that slope and
heading to a very strong direction that
this thing is gone now we could do it in
phases we can go to some areas which you
know some areas are much less effective
than others but it would be nice to be
able to open with a big bang and open up
our country or certainly most of our
country and I think we're going to do
that so you look at what's happening I
would say we're ahead of schedule now
you hate to say it too loudly because
all of a sudden things don't happen but
I I think we will be sooner rather than
later but we'll be sitting down with the
professionals we'll be sitting down with
many different people making a
determination and those meetings will
start taking place fairly soon experts
tell you to do it yeah I would rely very
heavily on them for monitoring and
testing yeah we're putting in very heavy
testing systems we have the best testing
systems and again don't forget when we
look at cases I'm looking at some I'm
not going to insult anybody I'm not
gonna result any country but I'm looking
at countries that are showing less cases
than testing we're testing more than
anybody and use you so exponentially
more than anybody by far and our
testings become I think it'll end up
being a big strength in fact the other
countries other countries that the media
talked about are now calling us for what
are we doing and how are we doing it so
quickly and where are we getting these
tests because our tests are really good
now they've been proven to be very
accurate yes thank you president talk
about two good questions yeah the one on
infrastructure members of your
administration and members of Congress
have pointed out the top paid federal
employee it's not the president it's
the head of the Tennessee Valley
Authority and he made eight million
dollars last year and some ridiculous
it's ridiculous I think it's the highest
paid government long before I got here
you said Tennessee Valley Authority
right has to be the highest paid man in
any government makes approximately eight
or nine million dollars I don't know the
gentleman but he's got a heck of a job
he gets paid a lot of money it's been
there for a long while has day yeah
that's separate but I'm talking about
the the we just have seven new people
going on the board I know but as you
know that's a quasi public agency and
whoever the head of the agency is that
person makes a lot of money question
which is an amazing thing right and when
we want them to do something they're not
there for us that's not good that's not
good the same been there for a long time
that's been a story for a long time that
you would support reducing that salaries
part of the infrastructure bill yeah
reducing it by a lot my other question
is that raise job in the history of
government almost certainly if you're
into money Tennessee Valley Authority
that's right go ahead I'm so elated for
somebody to ask me about that it's been
it's been bothering me for a long time
to go ahead so one of the biggest
reading hits of the coronaviruses decide
from these briefings has been a show on
Netflix called a tiger King yeah and the
man who's the star of this is a former
zoo owner who's serving a 22-year prison
sentence he's asking you for a pardon
saying he was unfairly convicted your
son yesterday jokingly said that you
know he was going to advocate for it and
I was wondering if you've seen the show
and if you have any thoughts on
pardoning Joe which son must be done I
had a feeling it was time is that what
he said I don't know I know nothing
about it has 22 years for what what did
he do allegedly hired someone to murder
an animal rights activists but he said
that he didn't do that
do you think you didn't do it are you on
his side are you are you recommending a
pardon order you're not allowed to do
that you'd be criticized by these would
you recommend a pardon
I'm not weighing it on I don't think you
would I don't think you would go ahead
you have a question I'll take a look
is that your exotic that's Joe exciting
last week your top experts were saying
that we should expect a hundred thousand
two hundred forty thousand deaths in
this country you've been talking about
how it looks like maybe things are
plateauing are these numbers now being
revised downward I know you don't want
people to stop social distancing and
that sort of thing but what can you tell
us about the numbers I did are they
right yeah
my impression Jim is those were the
numbers that were set and they were set
as an expectation from quite a while ago
I think we're just doing much better
than those numbers if either of you
would like to talk about that fair
question want to come up yes so and I
think all of you many of you have done
the analysis of the same models that we
utilized and if you do the models of the
models you end up with that range at the
same time we carefully looked at Italy
and Spain and we are doing much better
in many cases than several other
countries and we're trying to understand
that we believe that our health care
delivery system in the United States is
quite extraordinary I know many of you
are watching the act now model and the
ìiî hme model from and they have
consistently decreased the number the
mortality from over almost ninety
thousand eighty eight eighty six
thousand down to eighty one thousand and
now down to 61 thousand that is modeled
on what America is doing that's what's
happening and I think what has been so
remarkable I think to those of us who
have been in the science fields for so
long is how important behavioral change
is and how amazing Americans are in
adapting to and following through on
these
behavioral changes and that's what's
changing the rate of new cases and
that's what will change the mortality
going forward because now we're in to
the time period a full mitigation that
should be reflected within the coming
weeks of decreasing mortality I mean
that's what we really hope to see we are
impressed by the American people and I
think models are models I've always
worked on validating I spent my life
validating models all over the world and
that's why we do surveys and
surveillance and we make sure that what
we think is right is right I think this
will change how people look at
respiratory diseases because it will
change what is possible when the globe
and particularly the American people do
this level of mitigation and I think as
I talked about yesterday we are still so
we are still in off really of the
American people strength in this and
following through just for a second
Directorate I think that's it we have
we've done they have done everybody has
done everybody a great job so those were
original projections and we don't want
to say anything about beating it yet but
I think we will have a very good chance
to beat them very substantial about this
Thank You mr. president
I just want to add to what ambassador
Burke said I mean this is a consequence
of the commitment of the American people
you know a lot of us have always had
challenges changing behavior whether if
it's exercising regularly or different
habits with smoking when it when it when
it affects us what's been remarkable to
watch here is how the American public
has changed their behavior when it
protects the vulnerable I think that's
really what I'm so proud to see
yesterday and a quick this yes or no
question like yesterday you said you had
not seen Peter Tavares memo on
coronavirus back in January February
were you ever reached on those memos did
you ever discuss those memos with
anybody I don't remember that I've now
seen the memo I saw it it was Peter says
a lot of memos I didn't see the memo as
you know world health was saying that
was not correct because at the time they
called it wrong but I didn't see the
memo but I acted as quickly as people
were shocked that I acted so quickly and
everybody thought I was wrong because I
did act so quickly as you know with
respect to closing the borders with
respect not only to China but with
Europe I closed the borders and I think
that was very important but no I didn't
see them at the time but I have seen it
since station could actually create more
body bags it's a pretty pivotal age and
what Oh what do you believe the concept
was of the u.s. pulling out its funding
up the W I think when you say more body
bags I think we would have done and he
would have been much better serving the
people that he's supposed to serve if
they gave a correct analysis I mean
everything was I said China centric
everything was gonna be fine
no human-to-human keep the borders open
he wanted me to keep the borders open I
closed the borders despite him and that
was a hard decision to make at the time
we were all together we made a decision
against the World Health Organization so
when he says politicizing he's
politicizing that shouldn't be but look
we spend four hundred and fifty billion
dollars four hundred and fifty two
billion dollars almost five hundred
billion last year hundreds of billions
in previous years and they got to do
better than that they got to do better
when you talk about politics I can't
believe he's talking about politics when
look at the relationship they have to
China so China spends 42 million we
spend 450 million
and everything seems to be China's way
that's not right it's not fair to us and
honestly it's not fair to the world okay
question in the back different outlets
that Jared Kushner's team is seeking to
create a national coronavirus database a
tracking system for patients who've been
diagnosed now his spokesperson said that
that's not true yeah it's not I have
never heard about it doesn't it sound
like a bad idea actually but I have not
heard about this okay I don't know if
I'd be okay I have to see it but it
sounds very scientific and it sounds
like it could be good based on tracking
but it also has to do with rights and
lots of different constitutional
questions I have not heard that at all
so some people are concerned it would be
like the post 9/11 Patriot Act that
ultimately led to the FISA abuse are
there any adviser abuse of which I was
the one abused and a couple of other
people in all fairness no I don't know
anything about it I haven't heard it I
mean I'll speak to him I don't I don't
think so
they would have told me I would have
known about it please because smaller
casinos and businesses that make profit
in Nevada from gaming in Nevada find out
they're not eligible for the carers Act
PPP money is this and I talked to one of
remember who said you mean because of
the number of employees because of the
numbering point at this wall business
and they thought gaming would be would
not be treated any differently than any
other business with this was it well I
can look at that I could look it's a
great state and I will take a look at
that strongly are you talking only the
smaller casinos yeah I'll take a look at
that fine I don't mind that please yeah
we'll take a look yeah we haven't heard
nobody saw me about it but I'll look at
it the great state they do a great job
so I'm gonna look at it very strongly I
understand what they mean please Thank
You mr. president terms of the economy
what
urge Americans to go back to work and
they don't listen to you would you leave
that up to the governor's to businesses
to citizens to decide when when it's
safe to stop social distancing well when
you say I think they're gonna listen
they want to go back
everybody wants they're going stir-crazy
they've been in those houses and those
apartments and there I mean they've
really been they've done a great job
again when you look the question was
just asked about you know about how we
doing compared to projections those were
just original projections the big
projection being 2.2 million people
would die if we did nothing that was
another decision we made close it up
that was a big decision that we made two
very smart people walked into my office
and they said listen these are your
alternatives and that was a projection
of I guess 1.5 to 2.2 million people
would die but we didn't close it up it's
a lot of people so if we do a number
that's tremendously smaller than that
now if we did close it up the numbers
got to a hundred to two hundred and
twenty million people so if we can stay
substantially under the hundred which
was the original projection I think we
all did a very good job even though it's
out a lot of people say it right for
that by me first
well right now we're I mean we're doing
well in terms of the numbers I can't
tell you in terms of the date you know
we don't want to we don't want to go
down and then we can start going up if
we're not careful so we have to be
careful as far as distancing social
distancing and other things certainly
for a while you know at some point
that's going away we'll be able to sit
next to each other and everything like
we have all our lives it's a very unique
thing this has not happened anything
like this of this magnitude since 1917
1918 the great pandemic that was that
was something but ya know I people want
to sit next to each other at restaurants
they want to sit next to each other like
normal at a football game baseball game
basketball game hockey game no we want
to go back to life
now the first period of time maybe we'll
go a little bit slower and maybe we'll
be talking about
distancing but at some point we expect
to be back like it was before and
hopefully it'll never happen hopefully
it will if it does happen it's going to
be in a hundred years from now the last
one 1917 that's something that's a long
time ago and that was a that was a
horrible thing Jim good yeah get back to
what you were saying yesterday about
people going to Wisconsin and voting
yeah in the middle of this pandemic
really putting their lives on the line
and you said well if they do that both
by mail
perhaps we'll have voter fraud in this
country is one of that you to voters in
five states Utah Colorado Hawaii
Washington Oregon all vote-by-mail can
you or the White House staff where your
campaign provide any evidence to back up
your claim the mail and voting is wife
with broad like the example you gave of
people working your rooms filling out a
false balance there and where's the
evidence he I think there's a lot of
evidence but we'll provide you with some
okay and there's evidence that's being
compiled just like it's being compiled
in the state of California where they
settled with Judicial Watch saying that
a million people should not have been
voting in you saw that did you wait
excuse me well I'm just telling you I'm
telling you in California in the great
state of California they settled and we
could have gone a lot further judicial
watch settled where they agree that a
million people should not have voted
where they were a hundred and fifteen
years old and lots of things and people
were voting in that place what I see and
you know every one of those states that
you mentioned is a state that happens to
be won by the Democrats and if you have
a position like me where it's registered
you're here and we're voting someplace
where I'm not I haven't left the White
House and I guess months other than to
you know ask a ship to you know wave it
goodbye to New York which by the way is
now going as you know being used for the
purpose that we're talking about which a
lot of people wanted wait a minute
well for the Republicans hasn't isn't
your concern certainly hasn't but if
you're a senior citizen and if you're
somebody that needs it I'm all for it
but they have to be very careful because
you know the things with bundling and
all of the things that are happening
with votes with by mail where thousands
of votes are gathered and I'm not going
to say which party does it but thousands
of votes are gathered and they come in
and they're dumped in a location and
then all of a sudden you lose elections
that you think you're gonna win I won't
stand for it well we're gonna find out
about the proof because you're gonna see
what's going on and I'm not going to
stand for it our voting system first of
all we should have voter ID when you
vote you should have voter ID and if you
send something in you should be sure as
a state and as a country you should be
sure that that vote is meaningful and
it's not just made fraudulently because
there's a lot of fraudulent voting going
on in this country this country should
have voter ID okay let's do another one
that are being distributed across the
country I think it's very systematic you
know we're distributing the hydroxi all
through the country it's being
distributed in large amounts we have it
coming in now we were up to 29 million
doses that we went to 30 million doses
but we have it coming in all throughout
the country and much of it's being
distributed in fact it'll start going
down what we have in our stockpile and
again it said you know I hope it works
again I'm not a doctor as you possibly
have found out I'm not a doctor but I'm
a person with common sense and we've had
some very good results over the course
including a woman who just reported it
two days ago yes
through the eHealth data system honey I
think no looking we're looking to
provide it in many different ways
in many ways were in certain instances
we've been asked in the case of Michigan
we've been asked who the governor of
Michigan would like to I think she's
become a big fan of it as a medication
as a as something that's going to help
with this horrible virus and we're
delivering it to the governments of
various states when they ask so certain
states are asking certain governments
are asking and we're delivering it
directly to the government yeah we know
many people around the world
I'll pay close attention to this
conference where you're from yeah where
are you from I'm from Taiwan good yes on
behalf of foreign media group I would
like to ask you two questions first
question is that the French president
home called
Iranian president rouhani and say the
euro has started to ship the medical
goods to Iran where you can see the
medical goods
yes that doesn't bother me yeah so will
you think there's any medical goods to
Iran it doesn't bother me no okay yeah
so the other question is that the world
also paying attention to the US election
so we are also we know that the Bernie
Sanders has didn't really drop out he
didn't really do it what about his
delegates I mean he said he's gonna keep
his delegates and which is sort of
interesting he's gonna keep his
delegates that he'd like to get more now
is he dropping out or not that's not
dropping out when you keep your
delegates and then you want more
delegates before you get to the
convention and it's a weird deal going
on there and I don't know why President
Obama hasn't supported Joe Biden a long
time ago there's something he feels is
wrong why is it he'll come out I'm sure
he's got to come out at some point
because he certainly doesn't want to see
me for four more years we're not we we
think a little bit differently you know
what I'll tell you it does amaze me that
President Obama hasn't supported
sleepy Joe it just hasn't happened once
it gonna happen when is it gonna happen
why isn't it he knows something that you
don't know that I think I know but you
don't know so it'll be interesting but
with Bernie I saw his standard fare
today I watched and I hope that a lot of
Bernie Sanders people just like they did
last time we got a tremendous percentage
of Bernie people and I think they voted
for me largely because of trade because
Bernie and I agree on trade we agree
that the United States has been ripped
off by virtually every country they do
business with the differences I've done
a lot about it and I'm doing more about
it and we've made incredible trade deals
including u.s. MCA the deal with China
and then all of a sudden that gets
disturbed by this virus situation but
China has to spend almost 250 billion
dollars on purchasing our products 40 to
50 billion dollars with our farmers and
the Bernie Sanders people are big
believers on what I'm saying on trade
and I got a lot of them in the last
election that surprised people but it
didn't surprise me now those are great
people they're great people but I just
look I'm looking at Bernie Sanders I
watched this morning and I said what is
that all about like you saw that the
delegates the delegates he's not giving
up his delegates he's keeping him and he
said he wants to get more of them and I
think he's doing it to negotiate I
assume but I don't know that's that's a
hard thing to do
yeah Jeff go ahead mr. president
Russia tomorrow and some other countries
to discuss a little crisis yeah oil
prices are at $23 oh that's good finally
somebody knows something with a
escalation what is your message to them
ahead of their meeting tomorrow will be
us consider a coordinated cotton
production
I don't think look we already cut you
know we're like very market oriented if
you look at Texas and if you look at
North Dakota and if you look at some of
our states that do this very well
they've already cut way back you know
they cut back automatically but in the
case of Russia in the case of Saudi
Arabia they increased production at a
time when you didn't need it and then
they got hit by the virus which knocked
out 40% of the market and now they're
flooded with oil
look I just say this you have two
countries that are getting hurt very
badly Russia is getting her that's a
primary source and Saudi Arabia that's
Sarah definitely their primary source
and it doesn't make sense that they
flooded the market for whatever reason
they did that for themselves it's a
argument that they had and I think
they'll straighten it out a lot of
progress has been made over the last
week and it'll be interesting to see
what comes out of OPEC tomorrow but OPEC
obviously for many years I used to think
OPEC was very unfair I hated OPEC you
wanna know the truth I hated it
because it was a fix but somewhere along
the line that broke down and it went the
opposite way and we have a tremendously
powerful energy industry in this country
now number one in the world and I don't
want those jobs being lost okay a lot of
good options Jeff beauties I might like
it even more now you watch let's see
what happens hopefully they can make a
deal let's go
[Music]
very anxious to go back to work oh
you're something optimistic putting me
still very vague
now that the ima Chi bomb specifically
has been adjusted down to 61 thousand
when are we gonna open back up can you
give us a better date is it gonna be
April 30th May 1st
you said adjusted back down 61,000 what
was adjusted by the I am the I am aging
model the one that originally predicted
like between a hundred and two what's
still a big number right 61 right that's
a big number
go ahead but can you give us a more
specific date well it'd be me first I
had a date and I thought it was a very
aspirational date it's turning out to be
very interesting cuz a lot of good
things are happening by Easter but I had
a very aspirational date I didn't think
he could make it I didn't say we would
do it by Easter but I said well wouldn't
that be great to shoot for Easter that
would be a great day a beautiful day
very important day to a lot of people
like me and like some of you in the room
maybe all of you in the room frankly but
Easter is a very important day so I had
aspirationally I said let's see if we
can do it at Easter you know but I said
it would be very tough and I was
criticized for that so I don't like
giving dates and that wasn't a date that
was just an aspiration that would have
been incredible but I don't think we're
gonna be very far behind and some of
these models are looking like Easter is
going to be a very important date anyway
because of the curve I mean it's hitting
the top and it's starting to come down
and one person said Easter is looking
like a good time so a good time for that
for heading down so we'll see what
happens look there's no reason to do
that we have a lot of good things
happening when I spoke to the governor
of Louisiana that he said Tony they need
far less beds and then he I said well
good because we're building a thousand
room additional we built them a thousand
the beds and now we're building another
thousand and I said listen is there a
way that we don't build I don't want to
build them if they don't need them in
New York and the Javits isn't too
heavily used it's ready to go two
thousand nine hundred beds plus we now
have the ship set for kovat if they want
to use it and we're using it for
governor Murphy
in New Jersey so we'll see what happens
but you know the numbers are coming way
down the ventilators were all set we
have a lot to go if we want but we're
not getting I'm not getting calls where
they need ventilators anymore so we were
right on those ventilators I'd love to
have additional ventilators for some of
the countries that are our allies and
our friends and even if they're not our
allies that our friends you're saving
human lives but I'd love to see if we
had some I mean we're making a lot of
ventilators right now we have a and they
take a while to make and they're very
expensive and they're very complex to
make but I'd love to be able to help
other countries once we're taken care of
but I just sent 100 ventilators to
Colorado and that was great senator
there was a terrific senator Cory and
Cory Gardner then he called me last
night he said could you get a hundred
ventilators for Colorado and we just
sent them out and they'll be there very
shortly so but it looks like we're in
great shape from the bed standpoint it
looks like we're in great shape from the
ventilator standpoint and you just heard
I ordered 500 million masks 595 s and
others and surgical but we ordered 500
million mess three hundred and two
hundred and they're going to be here
very shortly so we're really in great
shape and we started off with an empty
cupboard so I'm going to leave the vice
president and his group to handle it and
I will see you probably tomorrow okay
thank you thank you very much
you'll come up if you want well good
evening everyone and to our fellow
Americans south west good afternoon
we find ourselves in the midst of a very
tough week for Americans in areas most
impacted by the coronavirus new york
city area in new jersey louisiana
continued to focus resources and
attention on those areas and I know that
the hearts and prayers of the American
people are with with all of those
communities but in the wake of of more
than 1.9 million tests we see more than
400,000 Americans have tested positive
for the corona virus and sadly we've
lost more than 14,000 we we grieve but
as the Good Book says we do not grieve
like those who have no hope in this very
special week I know that the faith of
millions of Americans is a comfort to
them the President and I spoke to more
than 10,000 faith leaders and we were
able to express to them our gratitude
for the way that they're strengthening
the communities that they serve but we
also find hope in the numbers that dr.
Burks will continue to reflect on today
for as dr. Fauci explained yesterday and
in the days before the losses as
Grievous as they are that we are seeing
today are a reflection of people that
contracted the corona virus in many
cases before strong mitigation steps
were taken before the guidelines for
America fully took hold the cases
however and the new cases in the
hospitalizations are in fact a
reflection of of the results of what the
American people are doing and I want to
echo the president's and dr. Burke
statements today about the extraordinary
work the American people are doing
because we continue to see a great
progress low and steady numbers in the
states of California and Washington and
in the New York metropolitan area
New Orleans metro area Detroit Chicago
and Boston we continue to see evidence
of stabilization that should be an
encouragement to every American an
encouragement that we may may be
reaching the point where the impact of
the corona virus is beginning to level
off but it also should be an
encouragement to every American to keep
doing what we are all doing heed the
guidance of your state and local
authorities and for every American
continue to put the White House corona
virus guidelines for America into effect
an area of particular concern we were
briefed on this morning is the city of
Philadelphia I spoke today to Governor
Tom wolf and as we begin to see early
trend lines in Philadelphia I assured
him that we were going to continue to
flow resources and support to that
community but our message to the people
of the Philadelphia area is now more
than ever a practice the social
distancing so that Philadelphia and and
to some extent even Pittsburgh do not
have to endure what other communities
before them have had to endure also
today at the president's direction we
hosted a conference call with every
Republican member of the House of
Representatives and every Democrat
member of the House of Representatives
and we express our appreciation to
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and leader Kevin
McCarthy for convening these forums we
brought together key members of our task
force team the secretary of the Treasury
discussed the progress that we've made
on paycheck protection he reported to
members of Congress that so far we're
working with more than 3600 lenders
across the country and we've dispersed
more than 98 billion dollars in
forgivable loans now these are loans
that if small businesses accept this
money and use it to keep people on their
payroll over the next two
they'll be completely forgiven a
Treasury tonight will be issuing a new
FAQ frequently asked questions document
that will also make it clear that
lenders may use their own closing
documents for completing loan
applications and that information is
available at Treasury gov and sba.gov as
well dr. Burks dr. Fauci briefed the
members of Congress today on the latest
data they'll both reflect on that in a
moment we also had Admiral John pelagic
talk about our control tower system in
the extraordinary flow of supplies to
critical areas across the country we
also briefed on the disbursement of
resources to local hospitals of sima
Burma and gave them an update on what
the Secretary of State spoke about today
remarkable to think more than 50,000
Americans brought back home through
nearly 500 flights and and we thank the
members of Congress who have worked with
the State Department to identify family
members and groups that found themselves
stranded overseas and we were grateful
for that in addition to our interaction
with members of Congress today we spoke
with the president of the Henry Ford
Hospital Bob Rainey it is the Henry Ford
Hospital that is conducting a clinical
trial for hydrochloric won he expressed
great enthusiasm for the work that they
had done they had a they had a rather
overwhelming response to the initial
trial which is beginning this week with
3,000 people taking the hydrochloric win
or a placebo so they can March it and
match it but what what the president of
the Henry Ford Hospital told me is
they'd like to expand the test I put him
in touch with Steve Hahn and the FDA and
we'll be adding several more clinical
trial paths to look at impacts on
particular demographic groups including
seniors and of minority populations and
more on that in just a moment in the
category of supplies
and support and the president as of
today has signed 52 major disaster
declarations Vermont was the latest
approved and states have stood up some
27,000 National Guard that are aiding in
coronavirus response on the critical
subject of ventilators we do have
currently more than 8,000 ventilators in
our strategic national stockpile and
distributed more to the Navajo Nation at
a Colorado today but also today we
received the good news that the first
delivery of newly manufactured
ventilators from General Electric and
Hamilton arrived at the strategic
national stockpile and as the president
said we'll be adding newly manufactured
ventilators to our resources to be
available as as as the corona virus
epidemic reaches critical communities
around the country on the subject of the
air bridge for flights scheduled to
arrive today primarily focused on gloves
for our incredible health care workers
one flight alone had nearly 19 million
gloves another eight million another 15
million and the light and the American
people I think would be very proud and
to see this vast array of now well more
than 50 flights that are bringing in
supplies from all over the world and
again working through FEMA we're
directing those resources with the
guidance of our scientific experts to
the communities most in need as we
announced yesterday the White House
coronavirus task force has requested
that a CDC and our team assembled data
on the unique impact that that we're
seeing reported on African Americans
from the corona virus dr. Fauci spoke
about it yesterday and will reflect on
hit Dave on that as well tomorrow with
the Surgeon General and others on the
White House team will will be speaking
with leaders in the African American
community
and as dr. pouchy will reflect there are
have been historic challenges in the
health care of the African African
American communities particularly in our
inner cities and now more than ever I'll
just say from my heart to all of the all
of our african-american family members
now more than ever practice the
guidelines look after those most
vulnerable people that have underlying
serious health conditions it's more
important than ever that we all put
those principles into practice finally
today I'm going to have after we we hear
from dr. fowey and dr. Burks I'm going
to ask dr. Redfield to step up because
today the CDC will be publishing new
guidance on essential critical workers
who have been exposed to Kove at 19 but
don't have any symptoms don't have a
temperature and don't have any reason to
believe that they have the corona virus
the present moment the guidance is that
if you if you have been in proximity to
someone who did test positive for the
corona virus that the guidance of CDC is
that that even with essential critical
workers in industries from health care
to food supply that we ask people to
stay home for 14 days the new guidance
tonight will hopefully make make it
clear that there would be an opportunity
for those people playing such an
incredible role in our nation's response
to be able to return to work and to do
so safely and finally let me just say
again now how inspired we are the
response of the American people to the
corona virus epidemic each and every day
as we see the beginnings of encouraging
news the low and steady numbers in
California and Washington State and now
beginning to see numbers of
hospitalizations going down and new
cases leveling and in some cases going
down
we all hope it is the beginning of a
trend but we also hope it is it's an
encouragement to every American to keep
doing what you're doing not just for
your own health for the health of your
loved ones but because we we want to
make sure that all of us are doing our
part to make sure that the fewest number
of Americans possible are exposed to the
coronavirus given the fact that this I
remind you is three times more
contagious than the flu each of us has a
role to play in in slowing the spread
that's what the 30 days to slow the
spread is all about it's about
protecting your health it's about making
sure that that our health care workers
are in our health care system is not is
not overwhelmed by the coronavirus and
and ultimately it is about saving lives
we talked about the numbers and I'm
going to ask dr. Burks to come up and
reflect on them but I think all of us
know this is one American at a time
it's one heartbreak at a time and having
lost loved ones in my life just like
everyone here and everyone looking on we
want to work every day
to make that number of losses the lowest
possible and it will take all of us to
do it and to keep doing exactly what
we're doing through today dr. Burks
thank you mr. vice president I just want
to start where the vice president left
off I come out of the services army when
you we always talk about honoring the
fallen and I think for every American
what we can do now to honor the fallen
that have fallen and given them really
their deaths to this dis terrible
disease to the health care workers that
are then front lines trying to save
every single one to honor them and to
honor our elders and the individuals
that we know are at the greatest risk
for bad outcomes we all need to continue
to do our work yes the number of cases
have stabilizing or is stabilizing but I
do want to go through those
numbers with you because we talk about
these as micro epidemics in metro areas
and in rural areas so in the New York
metro area which includes obviously
northern New Jersey Connecticut and
Rhode Island there are still eleven
thousand new cases per day and their
positivity rate on their testing is
still in the forty percent plus range so
there's still a significant amount of
disease there and everyone needs to
continue to follow the guidelines New
Orleans metro area 800 new cases per day
but a serial positivity rate on their
testing of 28 percent Detroit metro area
1,400 cases per day 26 percent
positivity Chicago 1,200 cases per day
an 18 percent Boston 18 percent
positivity 1,100 cases per day Denver
has fallen to one hundred and eighty
cases today per day but still has 15%
SERO positivity and they're testing
California and Washington have stayed
stable at about on Seattle 350 cases per
day on the LA metro areas 800 cases per
day but their test positive rates are
remaining in the nine percent range and
so this really gives us some idea of
what it takes they have been
continuously mitigating imagine what
we're talking about New York going from
40-plus percent zero positivity and
11,000 cases a day down to the LA metro
area of 800 cases per day and 9 percent
so this is what when the president talks
about reaching the top and coming down
those are the kinds of things we need to
see and the only way we will see them is
if every American continues to follow
the guidance now in the Philadelphia
metro area where I come from it's 1,400
cases per day this of course includes
Camden the counties around the
Philadelphia Metro and Wilmington and in
the Baltimore and the Washington DC area
15 percent zero positivity and five
hundred cases per day and 200 cases per
day in Baltimore this is how we're
looking at it county by county
true by metro rural region by rural
region to make sure we don't miss
anything and we're triangulating testing
data with the attack rates with a
hospitalization with a number of cases
and really creating a mosaic of who
needs what when to ensure that every
American is served well I had a great
call today with a group of pediatricians
the head of the American Academy of
Pediatrics and with the American College
of obstetrics and gynecology behind the
scenes and working every day are the
pediatricians fielding those phone calls
from every concerned mother and of
course grandmothers like myself and
protecting our children every day to
ensure that they have access to the
medical care that they need while this
is happening and to every pregnant woman
out there
I was very reassured hearing from the
American College of obstetrics and
gynecology they have put amazing things
in place to protect every pregnant woman
they have been social distancing in
their offices they have increased all of
the disinfecting they have lengthened
the time between clients to every
pregnant women don't miss your
appointments if your OB thinks you need
to be there you should go and please
know that on the labor and delivery
wards they are doing everything to
protect you in their babies they are
committed to you they are absolutely
committed to you having a good
experience make sure if your physician
believes you should be in the hospital
for your delivery make sure you're
following their guidance we don't want
any pregnant women to suffer a bad
outcome during this time so again I just
want to conclude by thanking the
American people and recognizing the
number of people were losing per day is
serious to all of us and it could be so
much worse but our frontline health care
providers and the way they're talking to
each other about how to improve care for
every individual that they serve you see
them on the TV you see them in the
emergency room you see what they're up
against this is how we can honor them is
to make sure we continue to put as
Falchi always says put your foot on the
gas and make sure that we continue to
strongly mitigate and really protect
those with pre-existing conditions and
finally those pre-existing conditions we
know now include asthma so asthma
hypertension cardiovascular disease
diabetes on any of these conditions
renal disease no matter what age please
make sure you're following the
guidelines to protect those individuals
in your household we know they're more
susceptible to a worse outcome we don't
think that any one's more susceptible to
getting infected I want to make sure
everyone understands everybody is
susceptible to getting infected this
virus is very transmittable as we well
know but we need to protect those that
need our protection the most so thank
you all for what you're doing to get the
message out to ensure that we continue
to protect each other in this very
difficult time Thank You mr. vice
president I just to follow up and
underscore what dr. Burks has said as
I've said many times from this podium
the the spectrum of going from infection
to getting ill to requiring
hospitalization to intensive care to
death and what is the most striking
thing that obviously is so sobering to
us is when we see the number of deaths
we know now for sure that the mitigation
that we have been doing is having a
positive effect but you don't see it
until weeks later
remember this past weekend when we all
of us got up in front of this podium and
mentioned that this was going to be a
really bad week at the same time we were
saying that we would hope we would start
to see a little bit of a change in the
daily hospitalizations intensive care
and intubations and new york is starting
to see that so I say that but I dropped
back a bit don't get complacent about
that because what's gonna happen two and
a half weeks from now is really what's
gonna happen with regard to the people
who are getting new infection as dr.
Berg said everybody is almost certainly
as susceptible as anybody else to
getting infected it's what happens to
you
do you get infected and and again to
just keep emphasizing we need to keep
mitigating we know that if this is
something that is a strain on the
American public but it's just something
that we have not only the only tool it's
the best tool and to just shift a bit to
what we said yesterday regarding the
african-american community it is very
painful to see and I've seen it
throughout my entire medical career that
the health disparities and the minority
community but particularly the
african-american community puts them at
risk
apart from Corona rife our virus issues
puts them at risk for diseases much more
so than the general population the
double whammy that you suffer now is
when you have this terrible virus which
essentially preys in its ultimate
deleterious effects on people with those
underlying conditions and since that is
more predominant in the african-american
population we want to double down and
say to the young people to the elderly
people in that community to please try
as best as you can to protect yourself
if you're a younger person and to please
protect the people who are susceptible
your grandmother your grandfather your
elder uncle the people who have these
underlying conditions because we are not
gonna solve the issues of health
disparities this month or next month
this is something we should commit
ourselves for years to do but what we
can do now today is to prevent people
who are put at higher risk because of
the demographic group from getting into
a situation which is much much more
deleterious than the general population
so I plead with all of us in the
population but particularly for those of
us our brothers and sisters in the
african-american community because we
know that mitigation does work the
reason we know it works is the question
that was asked about the numbers that
why they came down of the projections
because remember what you do with data
will always outstrip a model you
do your models depending upon your data
and our data is telling us that
mitigation is working so again as dr.
Berg said keep your foot on the
accelerator because that's what's gonna
get us through this Thank You mr. vice
president I just wanted to follow up one
of the most important things we can do
is keep our critical workforce working
and I think you heard it said that we
have many different critical workforce
industries in this country
obviously first responders health care
workers but as you heard it's also
individuals who help maintain our food
supply etc so what CDC has done is that
we've really looked at the essential
workforce and how to maintain that
workforce particularly at this time as
we begin to get ready to reopen and have
confidence in bringing our workforces
back to work and so we've put out a new
guidance for essential health care
workers who've been exposed to the
coronavirus these are individuals that
have been within six feet of a confirmed
case or a suspected case and so that
they can under certain circumstances
they can go back to work if they're
asymptomatic is the vice president said
they could go back to work if they do
several things as we say here take their
temperature before they go to work wear
our face mask at all times and practice
social distancing when they're at work
well we'd ask them not to do where
they're at work is we want them to stay
at home if they're sick we want them not
to share objects that would be touching
their face and we would like them not to
congregate in break rooms lunch rooms
and crowded places and in the second
slide if we talk into the employers of
these critical industries we would ask
those employers to take the employees
temperature and assess their symptoms
before starting them back to work if the
employee does become sick we want them
to
I'd be sent home immediately we'd like
them to increase air exchange in the
buildings and increase the frequency of
how they clean
common surfaces and really begin to get
these workers back into the critical
workforce so that we won't have worker
shortage in these critical industries so
that's the new guidelines that CDC will
be posting today and those will be
available at cdc.gov
thank you dr. Redfield and we'll have
questions for anyone on the panel please
the 500 million mast the president
mentioned that are being developed are
those for health care workers or are you
planning to actually hand out mass the
American public I think the the focus
has been to make sure that our health
care workers and our health care system
has the supply and with regard to what
we're what we're gathering from
literally around the world and from
manufacturers in the United States is
first being deployed to States and to
hospital systems but I must tell you
that whether it be the Haynes company or
other companies we're we're seeing
manufacturers in America that are that
are recognizing the the growing demand
for mass by the American people and and
are spinning up production literally by
the hour but but our focus our
continuing focus is on on making sure
that healthcare workers have the
personal protective equipment to do
their job safely and provide the level
of care that every one of us would want
mr. president Kansas governor Laura
Polly says that she is pretty seven
requests to FEMA for supplies from the
stockpile and those have not been
fulfilled so Kansas beginning any of the
laterz because the request included
ventilators and does she need to be
calling the white house instead have you
spoken with her directly I have not
spoken to the governor directly but I'll
reach out this evening certainly in our
conference call with governor's this
week we were we spoke to them about the
approach that we are taking you know
traditionally governor's are accustomed
to when when a hurricane strikes the
Gulf Coast when wildfires strike out
west when flooding or tornadoes hit in
places like Indiana you're accustomed to
have a declaration of emergency approved
and then resources flow from FEMA in
this situation as we deal with a
nationwide declaration and an epidemic
what we've explained to governors is
that what President Trump has directed
is that we we leave no stone unturned to
find resources around the country and
around the world including ventilators
and we make sure as as the corona virus
epidemic impacts individual areas that
the health care workers and and the
families and the patient's impacted have
what they need when they need it and
what I would say to the people of Kansas
is that we're looking at their numbers
every day just as in the case of every
state in the country and and we're gonna
work our hearts out to make sure that
that as as the corona virus cases emerge
and we hope that through the great work
that Kansas has done on social
distancing and and mitigation the people
of Kansas have done a remarkable job
that that we may well be to a place
where their existing resources and
capacities are present but we want
people to know that that taking the
Council of dr. Burks and our entire
health care team we're focusing just as
we did first in Seattle California and
and now in New York New Jersey
Connecticut Louisiana the Detroit area
the Chicago
we're gonna make sure that those
resources go in that order
you brought up social distancing in the
work that campus has done there's
actually a controversy right now over
her order to limit the number of people
in religious gatherings to ten people
should states be telling religious
institutions how many people can gather
it gets to stop the spread of the run of
ours well the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America ask every
American to avoid any gathering of more
than ten people and that's on the advice
of all of our best scientific experts as
a way that we can we can slow the spread
but we as we've made clear to every
governor we we defer to our governors
and what they believe is the best
inappropriate practice in their states
and we'll support those local decisions
well I can I can speak to that just and
then I invite dr. Burks dr. factory to
come forward we do have I believe we
will have roughly four separate clinical
trials underway studying
hydroxychloroquine but it's important to
remember that that as the president's
made the point many times the FDA has
approved what's called off-label use and
so in consulting with your physician if
your physician determines it's
appropriate to write a prescription for
hydrochloric when we're working today to
make that available across the country
it's broadly available today as an
anti-malaria medication but we're
working around the country and
internationally to increase that supply
but we are we are studying it in in at
least four different clinical trials and
dr. Fouts you can speak to that so the
easiest thank you for that question the
easy way to find out is to just go
clinical trials.gov and it will tell you
everything that's there there are a
number of different clinical trials some
of which are randomized controlled
trials which as I've said many times
from this podium to me is the optimal
way to determine ultim
if something is safe and effective and
works but there are a lot of different
ways that that there's being looked at
it's being looked at against the placebo
it's being part of a multi-armed trial
comparing it with others there's a trial
that was recently started actually in
prophylaxis among healthcare workers so
there are several of these in addition
to that there's what was just mentioned
now that any physician in consultation
with their patient and back and forth
can make the decision to use the drug on
an off-label so we have two things that
are simultaneously going on we're having
actual formal clinical trials and the
off-label use issues are most at risk
but if we knew that blacks
disproportionately have fallen into that
category why wasn't the CDC prepared to
gather this data in real time to work to
fight this well I'm not sure but we have
the director of the CDC here that we
could answer that question but let me
let me try to - just take it from from a
different perspective the health
disparities that exist are not anything
that started with coronavirus they were
they were there so there isn't much you
can do about the disparity the thing you
can do is to make an extra special
effort to protect people who have the
underlying conditions so it's the same
way as we say well the elderly and those
with underlying condition unfortunately
the African cámara American community
has a much greater proportion population
for population of these underlying
conditions so the best weapon we have
right now is what I said in my opening
remarks is to do whatever we can to get
them to realize that what we need to do
is to protect them from getting infected
and to also protect them from
inadvertently and innocently bringing
the infection to people who have these
underlying conditions
thank you sir can you explain the
thinking behind these 100 ventilators
that were given to Colorado when other
states like Kansas have to have had
trouble getting ventilators and can you
say whether a personal relationship with
president is helping states like
Colorado get these ventilators I mean
there are 15 states that have more cases
than Colorado well what I can say is
that we've been watching Denver very
closely and like many of the other key
areas that I touched on we're beginning
to see some encouraging news but in our
interactions with with the governor and
with local officials and and and with
the senator we've we've made an effort
not only in Colorado too but around the
country to be particularly responsive to
states where where we've seen a growth
in cases but but I'm gonna let dr. Burke
speak to that as well there's a
literally beginning with New York New
Jersey Connecticut Louisiana the Detroit
area in Michigan and the Chicago area
there's a series of of other cities
including Denver that we've been
watching very carefully and while we're
beginning to see some encouraging news
we we want health care workers in those
communities to know for for certain that
that we're going to move resources into
those areas where we see significant
outbreak about whether whatever
individual governmental relationships
with the president are getting
I can tell you within that decision
complex is not just the absolute number
of cases it's the hospital capacity and
what each of those hospitals have so
remember I think a couple of days ago we
talked about how the states are sending
the information about ICU beds hospital
beds ventilator needs so different
states have different which I don't
think any of us probably knew before
this but there are some states that have
lots of ventilators and there's other
states that proportion to their
population or by their cases of kovat
have less and so I'm sure Denver and
Colorado fit into that model where there
were hospitals that had less ventilators
proportionally and were needed for the
cases that were seen so that's the kind
of analysis so every every state that
has case a little has a few cases more
than Colorado have all received
ventilators except for I think Texas and
that's just because they are just
starting we're gonna restarted Colorado
was one early on the curve so they have
many more people have moved through that
progress and our our need of ventilators
Texas is very early in their curve in
both Dallas and Houston so that's what I
was talking about each of these are a
microt curve that we have to follow
independently or we would may be making
general decisions rather than specific
decisions by geography
you're obviously a very religious man
you be going to church on Sunday we'll
be attending church right in the living
room at the vice president's residence
where we've been attending for the last
several weeks the advantages we get to
go to our home church in Indiana is that
the same example you'd like to see
churches around the country regardless
of what governors are saying you as well
well I think the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America are very clear
that during this 30 days we were calling
on every American in every state first
to listen to your state and local
authorities but right after that to
avoid gatherings of more than 10 people
avoid unnecessary travel use drive-thru
at restaurant instead of going into
their restaurant we we are as these
health experts have told you seeing real
evidence that we're slowing the spread
that these mitigation efforts are having
a strong impact and tonight as many
people even at this hour on the East
Coast are beginning to sit down to a
Seder dinner that's the beginning of
Passover and with Easter celebrations
this Sunday we just want to encourage
every American to to heed the counsel of
the guidelines put those into effect and
know that in so doing will hasten the
day will hasten the day that we put the
coronavirus in the past and and we we
reopen our country as you are both
probably where there's a lot of
misinformation conspiracy theories out
there about the coronavirus there are
some commentators who are suggesting
that the number of dead are being
inflated because they're saying that
people who are dying with other issues
are being listed as COBIT 19
deaths like perhaps you've seen some of
this commentary you may be too busy to
see it but it is out there what do you
say to those folks who are making the
claim without really any evidence that
these deaths are being padded that the
number of kovat 19 deaths are being
padded for example somebody who might
die from a number of factors but had
coronavirus are being listed as
coronavirus deaths and because of that
the number is being inflated that's fair
question converse yeah we've been
hearing the converse do the hearing both
sides of that you know I think we've
made it very clear I think every time
I've been up here about the
comorbidities and so they most of the
people and we talked about the Italy
data the majority of the Italians who
succumbed to this had three or more
comorbidities so this has been known
from the beginning so those individuals
will have an underlying condition but
that underlying condition did not cause
their acute death when it's related to a
kovat infection in fact it's the
opposite having an underlying condition
and getting this virus we know is
particularly damaging to those
individuals we don't know all the
pathophysiology I wish we did right now
we see the a lot of vasculitis where
Toni and I came from Toni actually dr.
Fauci started in the vascular disease
and Wagner's so I mean these are things
we have studied for a long time we are
trying to understand the pathophysiology
but what we can tell you at this moment
if you have asthma if you have renal
disease if you have diabetes if you have
hypertension these are pre-existing
conditions that put you at a greater
risk to having a worse outcome Jim just
just to add a comment to that because
you know having been through other
serious issues particularly the very
painful early years of hiv/aids when
people talk about conspiracy theories
you will always have conspiracy theories
when you have very challenging public
health and crises they are nothing but
distractions you know I can assure you
we have so much to do to protect the
health and the welfare of the American
people that I would just hope we just
put those conspiracy stuff and let
somebody write a book about it later on
but not now performed because some of
the labs the machines aren't running did
you want to clarify that what did you
mean by 80 percent weren't running so I
have a call with them at 8:00 p.m.
tonight every single one of those
hundred and twenty laboratories I think
87 of the laboratory directors have
confirmed that call it has to do with a
machine called an Abbott M mm it's a
very high throughput machine we have a
million tests out there
I made a big push and Abbott was
extraordinary about getting those out to
the labs I mean this is not sitting in a
warehouse
these are physically in these
laboratories sitting there right now
they're not running so we've only run 88
thousand tests in three weeks off of
those machines with a million test kits
so as someone who has worked in a lot of
laboratories to have a machine that is
needed because we could have screamed
every healthcare worker these machines
are every place in the country so they
could have screened in these last three
weeks a hundred percent of the
healthcare workers across the country
that needed these wrap these tests to be
done and they're high throughput so I
have a call with them at 8 o'clock
to really talk about
can an award be given well I asked the
vice president to give me a chance to
talk to my colleagues first but we have
a call with the CEOs of those hospitals
tomorrow a really important question and
it underscores the fact that dr. Burks
pointed out that with this new new test
Abbott Laboratories we there
FEMA's been busy distributing to states
around the country we purchased 1200 of
these machines to be able to do these
tests but there's 18,000 all across
America and so let me let me just renew
our call to all that all the hospital
administrators and lab operators around
America to go and and identify those
Abbott Laboratories machines and know
that that's while we've already tested
more than 1.9 million Americans are our
short-term objective is to test as many
Americans as possible as this as we see
the corona virus epidemic emerge in in
areas around the country we want to
surge those resources we want states
that haven't seen a significant outbreak
to have access to that 15 minute test
and and ultimately we as we go forward
once we as you know I think President
Trump said today nobody wants to open
the country up more than him and I can
attest to that but we're gonna open it
up when we can do so responsibly putting
the health of America first and into to
reopen America and stay open America
we're working around the clock to
continually expand the kind of testing
that will allow us to do what these
experts call surveillance so that in
every state in the country once we put
this chapter of coronavirus behind us we
hope and trust sooner rather than later
that when next fall comes that we will
have a vast array so that CDC can do
what it does so well and that is when a
particular disease emerges CDC surges
per
Sanel does contact tracing isolates that
individuals so we're just really calling
on I'm calling on all of our partners
and in in the laboratories and in
hospitals around the country to to
identify those abbott laboratory
machines and and help us continue to
scale up and expand testing but to every
American let me again just say thank you
thank you for what you're doing we are
in the midst of a week of heartache and
I want to assure every American who has
suffered loss that we're with you we're
praying for you and your families and
we're and and we'll continue to work our
hearts out to make sure these incredible
health care workers who are inspiring
every single one of us all across the
country every day have the resources and
the support and the equipment to do
their job safely to provide the level of
care that any American family would want
for their loved one and to be able to go
home safely to their families and the
key to all of that the key for the next
22 days it's 30 days to slow the spread
and I just encourage every American if
you haven't done so recently go to
coronavirus gov print off your own copy
pick up the phone and call a friend and
just tell them that that you heard from
the experts you heard from the president
and our team that we're beginning to see
glimmers of hope extraordinary progress
in California and Washington is a
tribute to the people of those states
and the leadership of those states but
the the beginning of stabilization and
perhaps even leveling in New York and
New Jersey Louisiana and Detroit is a
testament to the people of those
communities to the leadership of those
states but understand that every one of
us has a role to play to protect the
most vulnerable among us and to save
lives by putting the guidelines into
practice just like you've been doing
every day since they were first
announced so thank you all and we'll see
you tomorrow